les traditions ont la vie dure en france
les vitrines de noël des galeries
lafayette fermé et placardé hier était à
nouveau bon dès ce dimanche
ce papa n'a pas hésité à l'envi de venir
les admirer avec femme et enfants malgré
la casse et les affrontements de la
veille
parce que la vie normale reprend oui il
faut bien toute façon un pari c'est
toujours un peu comme ça on n'a toujours
connu des événements un peu difficile et
puis voilà après en coin dessus
signe que les autorités s'attendaient au
pire les monuments et sites touristiques
importants de la capitale y compris la
tour eiffel était fermée hier les
visiteurs sont revenus deux fois plus
nombreux
moins de 24 heures plus tard cette
touriste brésilienne était très inquiète
elle a quitté la ville avec son fils
pendant les manifestations
tout comme cette jeune femme de grenoble
et gilet jaune m'ont fait peur donc je
ne suis pas artiste
la vie a repris son cours rapidement sur
les champs elysées aussi lieu principal
des manifestations et des affrontements
entre casseurs et policiers
les dommages ont été moins importants
que la semaine précédente
la plupart des commerçants s'étaient
bien protégé mais pas tous
plus de gilet jaune sur la grande avenue
parisienne sauf peut-être cet
agriculteur venu du sud de la france il
ya des des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui sont prêts à continuer le
mouvement tant qu'ils changent pas ça
c'est clair
après un 4ème samedi consécutif de
manifestations majeures et coûteuse le
gouvernement n'est pas resté muet
d'abord le ministre des affaires
étrangères a tenu à remettre à sa place
le président américain qui a blâmé les
dirigeants de la france jeudi à donald
trump le président de la république lui
a dit aussi nous ne prenons pas parti
dans les débats américains laissez nous
vivre notre vie de nation le ministre
des finances a jugé que ses
protestations étaient catastrophiques
pour l'économie
ces pillages et ses violences de la cci
leçon
inacceptable il n'y aura pas de dialogue
possible sans un retour préalable alors
au public
l'elysée annonce maintenant que le
président m'a qu'on va rencontrer des
partenaires sociaux dès demain c'est à
dire des représentants des associations
patronales et syndicales pour les
consulter avant de faire son annonce à
la nation le président macro est
directement visé par les critiques par
les manifestations
depuis des semaines il devra faire
preuve d'une grande habilité
s'il veut résoudre cette crise qui le
fragilisent de jour en jour il si
sylvain desjardins radio canada à paris